SERVED.
OUR CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC WILL
SURVIVE.
JOINING US NOW, FREEDOM AND
CAUCUS CHAIRMAN MARK MEADOWS.
I'VE GOT TO GIVE CREDIT TO BOTH
OF THEM AND THE ENTIRE FREEDOM
CONGRESS INCLUDING DOUG COLLINS.
IT'LL
IF YOU'RE QUESTIONING THAT
NOBODY KNEW BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS THAT GOT US NEW INFORMATIN
DOORS THAT GOT US NEW INFORMATI.
GOOD TO SEE YOU BOTH.
MARK MEADOWS, IT'S NOW BEGINNING
TO UNRAVEL, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL?
IT'S OVER.
MUELLER IS DEAD.
IT'S FINISHED.
THEY CAN CLING AS TIGHTLY AS
THEY WANT TO THEIR SINKING SHIP
AND THE CONSPIRACY THEORY.
BUT WHAT IS COMING IS FEES
FISA ABUSE.
THE RATE INVESTIGATION INTO
HILLARY, THE ATTEMPT TO BLUDGEON
AN UNDUE WIN ELECTION, THE
ATTEMPT TO STEAL AN ELECTION,
ALL -- WHERE ARE WE GOING TO DO
THIS?
>> BY DAYS, I MEAN JUST A FEW
DAYS, WE ARE STARTING TO SEE A
LOT OF THIS UNRAVEL.
PART OF WHY YOU ARE SEEING,
HEARING NADLER AND OTHERS GO
CRAZY BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT THE
TRUTH IS COMING OUT.
AND FOR AS PASSIONATE AS THEY
WERE TODAY AND MY GOOD FRIEND
JIM JORDAN DID A GREAT JOB IN
THAT COMMITTEE HEARING, BUT AS
PASSIONATE AS THEY WERE TODAY,
THEY HAVEN'T BEEN PASSIONATE
WHEN WE'VE BEEN IN THE PRIVACY
OF THOSE ROOMS, ASKING THOSE
QUESTIONS LIKE JIM AND I AND
OTHERS HAVE.
THEY WON'T EVEN LOOK AT THE
DOCUMENTS BECAUSE THEY DON'T
WANT TO KNOW THE TRUTH.
AND DIRECTOR COMEY?
HE HAD HIS DAY OF RECKONING TOO.
HE SAYS THEY INVESTIGATE?
WE ALSO KNOW THEY CRIMINALLY
LEAKED AS WELL.
IT'S TIME FOR ACCOUNTABILITY.
>> Sean: IF THE LAWS APPLY
EQUALLY, DO WE HAVE TO GO BACK
TO HILLARY AND THE RATE
INVESTIGATION?
BY THE WAY, YOU TWO GOT THE
INFORMATION, YOU DIDN'T SHARE IT
WITH ME.
WHICH BY THE WAY, I DEEPLY
RESENT.
BUT I KNOW, BECAUSE OF THE
CLOSED-DOOR TESTIMONY, AFTER NIN
CLOSED-DOOR TESTIMONY, AFTER NIE
MONTHS, THE FBI HAD NOTHING.
BUT WE ALSO, STROZK AND PAGE,
RIGHT IN THE SIDE INSIDE LORETTA
LYNCH'S OFFICE.
BUT WE'LL SEE WHAT --
THIAGO COMEY SAID THE SAME
THING.
STILL HAVE NO EVIDENCE.
TO JIM COMEY THOUGH, TO NOT USE
THE WORD "BUYING," REMEMBER WE
GOT FROM "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
BUT WE GOT THE STORY LAST
THURSDAY WHERE THE FBI PUT A
PERSON POSING AS SOMEONE ELSE TO
PERSON POSING AS SOMEONE ELSE TT
PERSON POSING AS SOMEONE ELSE TL
PERSON POSING AS SOMEONE ELSE TK
PERSON POSING AS SOMEONE ELSE TE
PERSON POSING AS SOMEONE ELSE TR
PERSON POSING AS SOMEONE ELSE TP
PERSON POSING AS SOMEONE ELSE TD
PERSON POSING AS SOMEONE ELSE TU
PERSON POSING AS SOMEONE ELSE TO
PERSON POSING AS SOMEONE ELSE TS
PERSON POSING AS SOMEONE ELSE T.
>> Sean: WE HAD A 30-YEAR-OLD
FLIRTATIOUS SUGGESTED BLONDE
BOMBSHELL SPY TRYING TO
SEDUCE INFORMATION OUT OF GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS.
YOU CAN PUT THIS IN A BOND
MOVIE.
>> IF THAT'S NOT SPYING, TELL ME
WHAT IS.
I DID NOT KNOW ANYONE WHO PUTS
MUCH WEIGHT INTO WHAT JIM COMEY
SAYS OTHER THAN CNN.
>> Sean: WAIT A MINUTE, WHEN
HE SIGNED THE FIRST PFIZER WARD,
WAS THAT BASED ON A DIRTY
DOSSIER WHICH COULD BE RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION ACCORDING TO THE
THE
IS THAT NOT SPYING OR AM I OUT
OF MY MIND?
>> IT'S WORSE THAN THAT.
HE ACTUALLY KNEW THERE WERE
CREDIBILITY PROBLEMS.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
>> Sean: MARK --
>> THEY DIDN'T TELL THE COURT
THAT CHRISTOPHER STEELE WAS
DESPERATE TO STOP TRUMP.
BUT YET THEY USE THE DOCUMENT.
>> Sean: I BELIEVE THAT WOULD
BE FOOTNOTE EIGHT IN THE
DOSSIER, IN THE APPLICATION.
THE APPLICATION -- YOU GUYS
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG AND
THANKS FOR NOT SHARING ALL THE
SECRET INFORMATION.
YOU GOT THE INFORMATION FROM
BRUCE OR THAT HE WARNED
EVERYBODY THAT HATED TRUMP,
WASN'T VERIFIED, HILLARY PAID
FOR IT.
BUT NOW WE HAVE STEELE AT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
>> EXACTLY RIGHT, SEAN.
>> I THINK THERE WILL BE GOOD
REPORTING THAT'LL BRING ALL OF
THIS TO LIGHT IN THE VERY NEAR
FUTURE.
>> Sean: BY THE WAY, BOTH OF